um okay so listen the amadeo thing
yeah here's what's funny so like i have
pictures of him with these fighter jets
right
yeah and he had
actually was trying to buy or was
negotiating to buy
a bunch of like f-15s and f-16s like
used ones you can buy used f-15s
16. okay this is before he had before he
um
before the whole uh congo coup thing
where the
where they uh backed a political
candidate and uh right right all the
mercenaries got arrested how about how
long before that
was this this was i don't know like six
months or so before
oh two thousand and
eight or nine 2008 or nine yeah or
something like that so
he and i could be off on the dates so
uh what what ended up happening was so
he had told me the story
and i saw the pictures and i'd and i you
know
and i'd seen some the documents and i
was like but i still nothing was like
concrete
like i got this guy who you know i've
seen him say crazy stuff so i don't know
for sure
if what he's saying is true so then when
i get out and i go and i interview
a couple of his associates i'm really
waiting for them to say
what are you talking about he was at an
air show he didn't ever try and
negotiate and buy planes what
jets what are you crazy bro
every one of the guys that i did they're
like yeah the planes yeah i know
they're like yeah in front of them and
stuff yeah i thought i kind of thought
like maybe it was a photo op
or something these guys are like no no
he he was trying to buy planes and you
know i wasn't a part of that deal which
guys
they're saying this um guys that were
that were had worked for his company
okay um one of the guys was uh
god this guy named uh woody johnson um
woody johnson what a name huh anyway uh
it wasn't
yeah well the woody's his nickname
anyway um the point is is that like him
uh uh there's there's uh multiple people
and they basically told me yes he's not
he was negotiating to try and buy these
these planes he also he owned a security
company
um a private security company he had
guys from uh
x he had x military working ex special
forces how much was he gonna pay for all
these planes
um i have no idea i don't know what it
what i i haven't how many of them i
haven't written down he was trying to
get like
20 of them or something he's trying to
take over the congo
and take over all of africa you're going
to need some planes he's negotiating
with the cypriots
to try and put the plane you might need
a few he's got 180 million dollars and
more on its way
he can buy some you can buy a used a
used f-15 f-16 you can buy them for a
couple million dollars a piece
so for can you really yeah they take the
guns they
take all that
they gut them and then they put then you
can bring them you can bring them
outside the united states and you can
have all this [ __ ] put back in
yeah and that's what happened you hire a
bunch of guys from
a bunch of russians that will come in
and they'll pat you bring them to
cypress or something
anywhere the congo cypress anywhere you
bring them there
and then you can hire guys to come and
put all the guts back in them and now
they're fully functional
i mean bro i've interviewed a cia
agent about his his whole story he's
read the story the guys researched it
he's looked into it
i got quotes from him he basically takes
the whole thing apart and the problem is
everything he's saying is like listen
this is legit stuff
like everything that's happening is like
everything i've thought that was i was
going to be able to
kind of almost debunk it none of it's
being debunked it's all being
supported like people are like yeah that
happens
i'm like are you telling me he was about
to buy a bunch of plans they're like so
he's
he might be a cycling schizophrenic
sociopath
but he's not bullshitting but he's not a
liar right exactly yeah
listen i mean you know he backed a
political candidate who's trying to take
over the the congo the guy
probably would have won if they hadn't
arrested all of his guys in the congo
i mean this this guy is off the cha it's
a great story it's a great story
and i'm blowing it up and i'm doing
doing as much as i can without being
able to actually talk to him
yeah you know so before you go to write
the book do you
i mean do you write it in sort of like
an essay format where you
break down like each main part of
like the story into like a like a
skeleton
well i yeah like so do you do it like an
essay where you kind of expand on each
it's more like initially it's a
chronological outline that i do
then i determine what i'm going to turn
into actual
what what is what's so funny listen last
guys
last time some guy was uh guys were
telling me oh there was this
jerk on the [ __ ] thing he was calling
you a [ __ ] rat and a scumbag and all
that
stuff
talking about me and i stopped and i was
like no he's talking about me and i was
and and i was like i kept hearing these
guys snicker that must have been what it
was about
they didn't say anything they want to
see you draw a rat i knew i see i knew
i knew it would you do a live drawing of
a rat give me a [ __ ] pen and a piece
of paper
yeah buy this for [ __ ] canvas yeah
oh i i brought the little canvas because
i was like you should do a live
i'm not going to draw my on the canvas
no i was just saying like i was i don't
know why i bought that sell that canvas
for if you just threw a rat on it right
it's a cam
i don't i don't know what well then i
gotta mail it to some the problem isn't
the
campus you gotta you know it's expensive
to miss like it could be forty or fifty
bucks to mail
somebody will buy that quick i guarantee
you that's a that's a little more
approachable
drawing right on there
no no i'm just saying well what about
150 you could ship that
so luke will hold the canvas for you
right here
so set it up like right here yeah there
you go and then you can what
what do you mean a permanent marker oh
this is a permanent marker
yeah that's a nice marker too is it all
right so
matt matt hold up put the mic put the
mic to your face so you can talk while
you draw it
and you're gonna walk us through your
portrait you're drawing a rat a rat yeah
unfucking believable [ __ ] scumbag
[ __ ] scumbag [ __ ] walmart
working [ __ ] walmart yeah
[ __ ]
are you serious i'm supposed to draw
this yes oh [ __ ] are you sitting like
for you bringing my canvas i don't even
know what i'm gonna draw just think of
me as a diesel
oh my god what am i doing oh this is
great
let's see so what are you doing now
explain this explain to me
it's uh i'm gonna say how are you
feeling right now what am i feeling
i'm feeling like like this is
like you know happy no not happy
i wonder how long that takes that's
pretty quick
it looks good from here this is sick wow
look at that [ __ ] sick dude
unbelievable [ __ ] rat
it's like master splinter
the first ninja turtles that's a [ __ ]
mutant rat
i don't know what a rat looks like i
mean what
that's a thick ass [ __ ] rat bro thick
boy
this is a salt rat yeah i think this is
uhd
this is what a fine arts degree gets you
right here yeah that's it
there's your [ __ ] i'll sign it hold
on it's not art until you sign it
you should do all your signatures on it
there you go
can you sign gary scary seriously
oh [ __ ] um let's see
bam
that's a [ __ ] masterpiece right we're
done
that is a masterpiece so sick you're
killing me
let's move the microphone so we can see
it better yes let's get a mic for this
painting
you know what's funny is uh how much how
much for that matt
we got any offers in the chat any offers
in the chat
we just did a live live art
live art drawing of a rat by
by matthew b cox aka gary sullivan
bob ross is turning in his grave right
now
we're accepting offers on this on this
masterpiece
so leave your offer in the chat that's
awesome
all right let's go we can put it over
there by that painting did you see what
i
did you see what i had that on my
channel the last review what i've
i named it [ __ ] what did i name it i
named it
is it in frame that's awesome
it's a little bit off push the other pin
here it is i put
i put i'm sorry that there is intense
i called it i called it con man rats out
criminal con man rats and i reviewed the
movie criminal
there you go well that was amazing i'm
glad that we just did that that was cool
i hope we get to sell it um what do you
think 100
right now i'll take a hundred dollars do
you get 100 for that
i think that's a deal
you got to pick it up for 100. you got a
you got a paypal
matt cox 100 150 and it's free shipping
150 for
free shipping yeah oh i bet you that's
not
yeah that's probably three years that's
cool
they got all the guy that i sent it was
like it's like a hundred and some odd
200 bucks to ship something to
it's like 200 bucks 150 was it 140 150
bucks a ship
to uh texas um
right now for that idea stink lines
shout out to
sync stink lines helping us remotely
right now all right
in an unnamed location actually you know
what
it was two hundred dollars to ship that
that's what i was just thinking i
shipped two paintings
for 200 bucks okay so it's like a
hundred and some odd dollars a piece to
ship the paintings
because i paid two hundred dollars to
ship one painting about a month ago
that was four foot four foot by five
foot though it was huge
you